[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here uh let's talk
about that roadster too so last night as
many of you probably know if you're a
tech fan at all you've watched these
before there was a tesla event and this
one was for the unveiling mostly as we
all knew it for the semi truck so we
finally got our first look at it you
know elon rolled up on stage driving one
got out of the thing looks like there's
two versions of it comes in a sort of a
space gray dark version one big one
small 500 mile range zero to sixty in
five seconds when there's no payload or
zero to sixty in twenty seconds with an
eighty thousand pound payload the thing
will recharge to 400 miles in half an
hour has a center seated driving console
autopilot all these cool things about it
looks really cool but and i'm not a
truck driver so i'm probably never gonna
actually even sit in one of those but
that was the main
story of the event
and then it kind of looked like it was
ending the lights dimmed and then they
came back on and there was music and it
became this sort of a
one more thing tesla pulled one more
thing and out of the back of one of the
trailers attached to the tesla truck
they rolled a tesla roadster 2.0 the new
one the one that we all knew was
eventually coming but didn't know we'd
ever see you see tesla didn't have much
of a reputation when the original
roadster came out that was this two-door
car that was essentially the body of a
lotus but with the electrics of tesla
the motors and the batteries and it was
a sort of a weird frankenstein hybrid
car not the most practical thing not the
most comfortable but boy was that thing
zippy and from what i've heard very fun
to drive but it doesn't supercharge the
way model s do it's not one of their
flagship cars uh they had problems they
didn't sell a lot there was a couple
hundred or a couple thousand sold and
that was it but then there were rumors
there were rumors of maybe they'll bring
that back maybe there will be a roadster
2.0 there are some elon tweets here and
there there's some tesla hinting
but we never actually see anything until
last night so they rolled that thing off
the truck and it looks
in my opinion absolutely incredible it
looks great it looks like a tesla in a
lot of the waves and a lot of the curves
but it has cues from others cues from
porsche a little bit from aston martin
it's got some some mclaren lines to it
so it's a really aggressive really
good-looking sports car it's pretty
clear immediately that he's about to
talk to us about the new roadster and he
is and then he gives us the specs and
i'm a spec person i like numbers
but there's not a lot of spec sheets
that can just make me kind of speechless
essentially especially coming from
someone who's driven and owned a p100d
for a while which has a silly spec sheet
by itself
spec sheet of the new roadster 0 to 60
miles per hour in
1.9 seconds
1.9 seconds zero to a hundred miles an
hour in 4.2 seconds it'll run out a
quarter mile in
8.8 or 8.9 seconds i've seen both from
their their website and their
presentation but it's a sub nine second
quarter mile it'll have a top speed of
quote
over 250 miles per hour and this all
will come from the floor mounted 200
kilowatt hour battery pack so twice the
size of the p100d it has three motors
two for the back wheels and one for the
front wheels and it'll do 620 miles or
621 miles rated for a charge so that
massive battery is actually getting you
not just awesome performance through
motors but a really long range that'll
be the first electric car to do over a
thousand kilometers on a charge so
that spec sheet just that list of things
he said just if you look at the car and
you hear those numbers
it's like hyper car territory basically
it doesn't sound street legal it doesn't
make any sense when you look at every
other car that's ever been produced it's
nuts and i know we get caught up in the
numbers about like you know it's just a
straight line drag race like eventually
those other cars will catch it those
million dollar super cars that we
constantly compare these two will
eventually catch it but with this one it
doesn't look like they'll catch it
nearly as fast as they could catch this
car like this is basically p
200 t
in a way like if apollo is p100d
performance 100 kilowatt hour battery
dual motors then this roadster is a
lighter body
a 200 kilowatt hour battery pack and
triple motors p200t so we get to this
point in the event my jaw is just kind
of on the ground where i was watching
this and obviously there's a lot of
comparisons naturally we just love
comparing tesla's numbers to these
million dollar super cars i actually
looked it up a lot of these cars on the
list of the fastest production cars 0 to
60 ever are doing like 2.5 seconds maybe
2.4 a lot of them 2.7 so for tesla
roadster to come along and do 1.9 is
disgusting and there's actually some
videos from the event that we're getting
some test rides out i'll show you guys
them but of actual launches from inside
the car the reactions incredible the
views incredible i can't wait to see
people doing like that gopro reaction
test where they're just sitting with the
passenger and they have the gopro up
here and they do the launch from 0 to 60
to see the reaction can't wait for those
three two one oh jesus
honestly i didn't think
i didn't think i noticed the difference
between my p100 come on no i honestly
didn't think it knows the difference
there's a reason this one's called black
oh my goodness
i kind of wonder if you could track this
car like i've talked to friends about
bringing like a tesla to a track and
actually you know racing a p100d against
other cars this car is electronically
limited to 155 miles an hour but you can
only go that fast for so long before the
battery starts heating up and it
actually limits your performance and
doesn't want you to do that for very
long so even though it's an insane
performer even though this car does 0 to
60 and 2.4
you wouldn't really race it on a track
for very long against like a traditional
supercar i mean it's also a four-door
sedan so that's another reason but still
i gotta wonder what the cooling is gonna
be like in this 200 kilowatt hour
battery how long you be able to get this
insane performance can you actually go
200 miles an hour for some time before
it wears out could you actually track
this car and beat a lot of the others i
want to see what motor trend does with
it i don't know i have a lot of
questions but one thing i haven't
mentioned is uh this car is coming out
in
2020 tesla roadster 2.0 will ship in
2020. there's gonna be a founder series
version and a regular base model
essentially is what he said uh i don't
know how the numbers will defer or what
the difference will be between the two
but that's what he said it'll be a 200
000 car which is i mean it's still a
fraction of the price of the million
dollar cars we compare it to but the
founder series will be 250 000 and there
will only be a thousand of them made now
there's a reserve button on their site
and
trying really hard not to press it but
you can reserve it right now to get it
in 2020 but there's plenty of other
questions i still have plenty of reasons
why you might not get this car like the
fact that i've only seen the outside of
it for example they haven't they haven't
shown the trunk elon said tons of
storage on stage but he didn't show the
front trunk or the back trunk he also
said it's a four seater so there's the
two doors in the front and you see the
front two seats but there's also two
pretty small seats in the back kind of
the way some other sports cars are four
seaters you probably don't want people
in the back all the time but then it's
also a convertible so the top glass goes
back into the trunk so how big could the
trunk really be i believe it will have
autopilot but that wasn't really
mentioned or talked about uh there's a
couple of other little things like i
still have questions about this car
but then again
2020 by then like this could be sick
something i don't talk about a lot is
this car p100d apollo is a leased
vehicle which means i'll be giving it
back and i kind of view tesla's as a
piece of tech in that way so the fact
that they offered a lease for a couple
years where i could give this piece of
tech back to them and they'll continue
to develop other tech that i can pick up
later when i gave this back was kind of
part of my plan and it turns out
apollo's lease is up at the end of 2019
and the roadster 2.0
2020.
but this roadster 2.0 man that's
something else that's a hyper car 0-60
that fast 0-100 that fast 250 miles an
hour
you can't you can't really argue with
that i think i'm done
i think that's all i had to say
uh let me know what you guys think
should i
should i
think it probably will